if you're in the back of a wrap you're
both in the back and they're knocking on
the front window I'll rest me now arrest
me now because I'm I promise you now if
I'm in the back you're naked I'm naked
naked and I'm not opening any windows
I will hide down like that if he's
knocking if it's steaming you can't see
[ __ ] and he's knocking he can keep
knocking
eyes
ladies
um
what's going on man
what is actually going on uh me if we're
just having talking we've just realized
that episode 100 is actually around the
corner it is around the corners episode
100's creeping up so if you've got any
fun ideas for us let us know
um don't say dumb [ __ ] don't say just
dumb stuff bro I tell you what I say
interferred yesterday like some of the
would you rathers that you man put in
sometimes just to get a feel for where
we're at I love to just ask what's going
on yeah
they got I'm going to stick this on the
guys because the girls come better
mm-hmm girls typically come more correct
yeah the guys
anything gay they can put in there
they'll just do it because I don't know
bro it's just like so unimaginative yeah
do you know what I mean and the thing is
I don't mind a jokey humorous
homerotic kind of would you rather but
some of it is just laziness I agree some
of it's just laziness like would you
rather wrestle a shark in its in its
home to rain with nothing but Coral to
save your life
or just [ __ ] suck off a stranger are
you like what
what are you talking about
yeah
it'd be more original yeah yeah yeah
like would you rather fight all night on
his best day or suck for your head off
you know what are you on about you had
me up first and then uh you're just
worried lazy lazy would you rather fight
all my Audi's best day
obviously but still lazy question
foreign
speaking of all my yeah I know you
haven't seen it yet Demon Slayer movie
bro Mugen train I know I need to watch
it I need to watch it the thing I want
to watch
um like uh what's the word I'm looking
for like a recap of season one because I
I did that before I don't know if you
spoke about if I spoke about this one
here but I did that for season one to
three of attack on time before I start
season four okay five minute recapping
Fair Play on YouTube I would say
actually to be fair with the movie even
though the movie is directly related to
the thing yeah you don't need to recap
oh really you don't it's a completely
separate situation okay as long as you
remember who the characters are yeah
they don't bring back any knowledge that
they've learned previously to utilize in
this okay
not really okay there's a few references
here and there that you'll be fine with
but like
yeah you don't need a recap so you saw
it in a cinema as well right oh yeah
yeah oh yeah bro
the movie's amazing dang
how long is it uh like two hours the
movie's amazing bro I can't wait amazing
I nearly cried twice really
damn these man they don't play well did
you not notice my background my man I
saw that I saw that yeah arms bro
because we've not seen him properly do
anything we've not seen him properly
yeah you've ever seen him do anything
yeah yeah arms bro
yeah they're on a different level I feel
like even though you said I shouldn't I
don't need to watch recap I need to I
feel like I need to if you want to I've
been a minute for me it's fine dude do
what you need to do bro
the
your face the movie's wild bro I'm here
for I didn't expect anything less from
it to be fair I didn't expect anything
less for me it's so live I'm I am
definitely looking forward to it
definitely it's like they did a thing
where it's just like it's almost like
two movies in one okay where they've
done a thing where they set up this
whole thing for the whole movie and this
is the premise of the movie um and then
they just like at the like the last half
an hour is just like oh let's do this as
well just just fit it in it still fits
but it's just like let's do this as well
does it do you think that bit you're
just talking about now that last half an
hour do you think that rolls into season
two
uh yes it kind of does
um
but yeah it's just you wanna you wanna
speak you can't say do you want to speak
about it because we're on the tip of
your time
bro yeah obviously clearly guys I've not
seen the movie yet so that's why he's
not it's not going on about it oh
amazing yeah
it makes me also want to be a better man
it actually makes me want to be a better
human being overall okay you just it's
one of the things where you watch it
there's a couple like Naruto ones like
that it reminds me of like uh you know
we see Rockley and he's training bro and
he feels like if I can't do 100
press-ups I've got to do 200 squats yeah
it's just like he wants to be the best
person he can be yeah in all uh like
facets and like that's like my man uh
what's his name ring Goku I think his
name is bro hmm
he's so he's up here at all times no
matter what's going on bro he's
his calm collected and just like
protective of everyone all the time at
all times bro no matter what's going on
he holds his morals so high okay no
matter what's going on I might watch it
today you're guessing bro you have to
watch it today you don't need a recap
I've got to watch it it's amazing bro
you have to watch it all right he's up
here family okay he makes me want to be
a better man damn he actually makes me
want to do better bro all right but but
I'm gonna watch it yeah I'm gonna use
him he is the fire behind my Titan
for the gym yeah okay okay on another
level bro okay on another level yeah
it's on it's unbelievable they're so
good for it it's so good I'm here for it
um but yeah definitely yeah definitely
jump on that that's so sick ah wow wow I
need to watch it again
um because it's all like it's online as
well and it's clear as well Crystal
Clear online I haven't even checked it
online but I'm assuming at this point
definitely is Crystal Clear online oh
okay but I know because there was people
I see people on Tick Tock doing um
always there's always links on Tick Tock
for the last few months there's always
been links on Tick Tock oh you can watch
Stevenson over here and then I would
like oh gang and then I'll click it
because I never knew it was going to
come to the UK Cinemas yeah so far I
don't have to watch it as well yeah bro
so I'm gonna have to watch it online and
then every time I click it it was trash
quality I was just I'm not willing to do
it bro
um so yeah when I saw it was available
on Cinema it was only available for two
days at the cinema near me Wednesday
Thursday Ting so I was like bang we're
there
um
okay oh it was wild I'm uh yeah but I
was like wild
staring at me wild bro
um I'm here for it but yeah that was
sick
um anyway guys well go on welcome
patreon
YouTube you know like subscribe share
the thing jump on the insta jump on the
Twitter jump in the comments bro jump in
my DMs everywhere man whatever whatever
bro we're available we're active yeah
we're here we're about
um
obviously guys hit us up with the am I
the [ __ ] um fan request hit me up
with some one's gotta goes as well guys
one's got to go yeah man some fun facts
yeah man we love it we love it it's all
good
um but yeah speaking of fun facts my G
what are you saying uh this week
um fun fact an Australian man Bill
Morgan was once declared dead but came
back around after 14 minutes to
celebrate he bought a scratch card and
won 27 000 of 1827 000 car days later
the news asked him to reenact the moment
so he bought another ticket he won again
but this time he won 250 000 that's
impossible bro
I'm gonna read the full tank so the real
story behind um the viral video
everyone's talking about an Aussie
Legend who won 250k scratch jackpot on
camera after waking up from a 15-day
coma reveals what happens next and it's
not all good oh wow okay
so Bill Morgan's life has been full of
luck good and bad he should have died in
June 1998 and for it and for 14 minutes
he did but somehow doctors managed to
revive him after he had a heart attack
and spent 15 days in a coma Mr Morgan
then 37 was living in a caravan in
Melbourne and was dubbed a medicine a
medical miracle sorry his second lucky
break came when he bought an instant
scratch card about a year later and
promptly won a brand new Toyota Corolla
worth 30k in dollars uh the Win 4
attracted a lot of media attention
and that's when it happened again his
claim to viral Fame re-emerged uh some
22 year 22 years later on everyone's
Facebook feed
um the feedback the footage sorry
captures Mr Morgan buying another
scratch card to he reenact the moment
only to win the jackpot he was like I
just won 250 250 000 sorry I'm not
joking he says to the camera in
disbelief I think I'm gonna have another
heart attack and this is his face
see face
that I need to see that video that's
wild that is wild no I'm gonna see if
there's an actual video of it because I
think there is but sometimes when I um
go to watch full video oh yeah go
I just won 250 000. I'm not joking
I just won 250 000.
what do you say I don't know please
don't cry
the [ __ ] is that yeah wow yeah Mom so
first of all how boring is wherever they
live in Australia that years after he
won this car they're doing a reenactment
a car a Toyota Corolla well it was a
1998 gee I think Facebook wasn't a was
Facebook about back then no I mean it
wasn't but like
still
the news
are doing a a story on my man for
winning a car on a scratch card
there must be nothing going on where
they live right 1998 I feel like there
wasn't that much happening in the world
they probably there probably was but
there probably wasn't as much like
because there was no social media none
of that yeah they were just recording
anything yeah you know yeah yeah so
that's crazy to imagine they were like
cool like we're just going to do like a
quick quick story on you when your uh
Toyota et cetera Etc
um so what we're going to do is we're
going to be narrating it
um and we're just gonna have some video
footage so if you could just buy a quick
scratch card now and then we'll record
you scratching it uh and then obviously
we'll talk about you winning the car and
all this stuff and then like yeah cool
cool cool man was actually scratching
this one I just won 250k you see him
scratch and you see his stop like you
see his hand just he's he's perplexed
because I just want 250k and he's like
oh no [ __ ] joking
I'm gonna cry I'm gonna [ __ ] cry I
couldn't win that money I couldn't ask
how are you now bro oh my God I Fall to
my knees I would afford to I'd be able
to breathe
hard need I'm not sleeping until that
money's in my account yeah there's no
pending yeah because I'm holding on to
that a piece of paper I'm holding this
fragile take me to wherever I need to go
now and now bro did you know with the
lottery and stuff yeah obviously if you
don't do it online if you actually do
like a scratch card yeah for example bro
it's sassena what do you mean it's
dangerous bro dude like
did you know that's basically it if you
win this if you if you get the scratch
card
I'm pretty sure if you read the back of
the scratch card it says like if you win
the big big bucks yeah they can't give
you yeah go to a spot you have to go to
a spot or if you can't get there you
have to put it in the post yeah I'm not
putting it in the post bro yeah yeah
I've read it yeah are you crazy I'm not
putting it in the Box I'm driving to
wherever I need to go yeah tell me where
I need to be at I'm not putting it in
the post because Postman Donnie already
knows this address he's familiar with
this address oh one million if I'm a
postman I'm familiar with that if I'm a
postman and I see that dress bro now
I'm swiping now open yeah yeah that's
not a game man I'm familiar with my game
bro
these posts these posties bro they do
what they want they do what they want
yeah my boy when I was in school his dad
was a postman and he told me he used to
teave things
every single day
um oh yeah oh hit me up with some
stories
um if you remember anything uh he teased
a couple phones uh some games no he'd
always be able to tell when there's a
card like a birthday card with money in
it so just open it take the money out
seal it back up no send them the card
yeah bro Postman don't care
I'm assumed this was when I was a kid
probably like 20 years ago of course I
know um but yeah I'm sure they've
tightened it up now sincerely hope so
but yeah I from then I've never put
anything valuable in the post [ __ ] man
never bro
even when I used to do like um
we buy any phone or whatever and I'd
sell my old phone on there when they
tell me to put it in the post I used to
be vexed so I figured this it goes like
that's the that's my money yeah that's
everyone yeah yeah yeah yeah and that's
when I was at Uni as well I did that all
this I did that recycle thing all the
time oh all the time yeah quick hundred
pounds I needed that yeah the same you
felt like the bell of the ball when you
got it 100 these times they give you pee
for it now you know
they give you paper I was going to do it
for my my old phone but the one before
this one so what did I have before this
what's this 11 11. I think I had the ten
okay I think they were going to give
they were going to run me like three 400
pound for it oh really oh she can sweat
um so what are you doing did you do it I
saw it to someone else oh okay okay for
like um 200 why
some oh okay fair enough yeah yeah fair
enough fair enough fair enough um mixed
race in that
um but yeah I hate putting valuable [ __ ]
in the most I hate because I just assume
it's gone I just assume obviously
nowadays I'm assuming obviously because
of what your friends pops told you back
then it makes sense but there's so much
more nowadays in terms of like tracking
blah blah blah so oh yeah it's a rare
well I've never experienced anything go
missing from my [ __ ] that I've ordered
or something something I'm expecting
yeah I mean the only thing for me is
like Amazon stuff and they'll just send
it to you again yeah true they can
afford that though yeah but like um like
uh you know Lewis he was doing like
Pokemon cards on eBay and stuff sick he
was yeah
he was making a bit of pee actually yeah
but um he was doing Pokemon cards on
there and like any time I see a decent
like a crazy deal like because a lot of
people don't know what their cards are
worth yeah yeah so he'd be buying stuff
on eBay and it could be like a card
that's worth like five grand but they're
selling it for like 50 Quid because I
just don't know so he'd be trying to buy
that and you buy that and bro he's until
it comes he's pulling his hair out yeah
he's pulling his hair out bro [ __ ]
thinking please come like please don't
get lost in the post please don't let
this person change their mind everything
just please run me this card I need this
card yeah yeah stressful Pokemon cards I
remember used to collect I used to have
a book club where you um had all the
slots in yeah yeah I'd buried him I
can't remember now I had so many of them
in primary school probably didn't roll
it I don't think it rolled over to
secondary school maybe it did but uh
what they're probably worth now would be
ridiculous because that's at least 20
years surely oh yeah bro people make pee
on Pokemon cards right now
I did for a while but obviously now yeah
bro like I had like a shiny um Blastoise
first edition Shiny Blastoise I had I
traded it for something stupid like some
sweets or some [ __ ]
right now that's worth money money cake
yeah let me actually Google it yeah I'm
going like Google yeah um
first edition Shiny Blastoise
what are like Worth or something like
that
shiny Blastoise
how much is the first edition first time
how much
how much is it worth uh 1999 Pokemon
game two blasters Holo first edition
card Mint Condition most recent price
five point eight thousand dollars
an SMR price which I don't know what
that means uh nine thousand dollars
yeah oh dear yeah I sold that for picker
mix bro yeah
someone on eBay is selling
a Charizard base set first edition
shadowless I don't know there's so many
thingies for nearly a quarter of a
million pounds bro these these things
are no game bro a quarter of a million
pounds yeah Pokemon's not a joke what
a man is charging 70 dollars for PMP
posted in packaging as well
he's not gonna be able to sell that he's
not he's never selling it
um
[ __ ] but yeah bro
I have cards I had cards but I don't
remember the cause I don't remember what
cards I had I just remembered that one
because I remember specific I even
remember where I was sitting in primary
school yeah because I remember it's the
same day my boy his name is Rafiq told
me
um
but he was Muslim and he was fasting and
that's the first day I learned about
what Ramadan was or anything and I
remember thinking this is the most crazy
[ __ ] I've ever heard bro what are you
talking about imagine I can imagine yeah
um yeah his name not rafik it's Sadiq
that's what his name was Rafiq I don't
even know Sadiq his name was Sadiq and
Mum was like yeah yeah I think I was
eating like a jam sandwich or some [ __ ]
and I was like how'd you do what's that
because it was lunch time he went eating
and then he was like no no no I'm
fasting and I was like you know what and
I said oh I'm not allowed to eat from
like when the sun's up and I was like
why and he was like oh like it's Ramadan
I was like big man what are you
you I keep I keep asking you a question
you're not answering
[Laughter]
every time I
was giving me a stupid answer what are
you on about do you want food or not got
this savage or not bro
um
and yeah he was like oh nice I'm fasting
it's Ramadan and I was like what are you
on about yeah it's Ramadan bro when it's
Ramadan you're not allowed to eat and he
couldn't even explain it properly yeah
but yeah it's like it's my religion when
it's Ramadan you're not allowed to eat
from when the sun's up you can only when
the sun's down and I was like so you
haven't eaten today he was like no I'm
not gonna eat until like lately and I
was like nah bro I'm hungry while I'm
eating you must be starving
starving and I remember I was sitting in
a bench on the playground yeah and I
remember thinking [ __ ] that and then I
saw my other boy uh playing Pokemon
cards and they were actually having like
an actual like battle or whatever and I
went and chilled over and then I had
like some cards in my pocket and I was
like um
Thunderbolt yeah mad
and then when I had like Donnie like pit
had a picky mix yeah bear Cherry Coke
bottles in there bro and I was like I
want that I want that and that was
saying
are you gone for me you're not having
nothing but and I was like come on man
run that yeah and he said all right cool
um and he was playing his Pokemon cards
and he was like oh have you got that um
shiny blasters because he asked me to
bring in just so we could see it he said
if you've got that Shiny Blastoise and I
was like yeah I got that of course
Australia musical you can have all of
them if you give me this and I was above
bear
bad
easy money you dumbass
easy money as soon as you did the
exchange he must have fought you
absolutely
oh absolutely you don't even know where
oh I was just sucking that fizzy Cherry
Cola like
this is life
such a kid such a kid's mistake bro
these times that's worth Brands Brands
now and I'm here broke Grand bro yeah
wow [ __ ] yeah I'd sell all of that now I
would oh for sure thing is as well my
mum keeps everything if I had that book
to keep it in mint condition and stuff
like that if I would have just had it as
a kid my mum would have kept it in a
filing cabinet if I just asked her to
like she would have kept it and it would
still be pristine until now
it would have been I could have cracked
that open and just be like
and then just bang grams shiny add cards
at a shiny Pikachu and Shiny Blastoise I
remember those two I'm certain I had a
Charizard I had I'm pretty sure I had a
shiny charizard how did Zapdos
yeah I had we had a Zapdos I just let
that one go mate yeah really yeah wow I
didn't have any legendary birds I had a
[Music]
um
I remember had a uh what was it
uh what once the
so it's
Machamp that's what I had okay a shiny
Machamp yeah yeah yeah
um and I feel like my Hitman Lee which
one's the kicking one
Hitmonlee yeah my Hitmonlee was shiny I
feel like it was I don't know why it
would be but I feel like my Hitmonlee
was shining too I didn't even know but
yeah bro [ __ ] those were those yeah bro
I got this football cards as well yeah I
had Yu-Gi-Oh cards too I don't think I'd
Hugo cards me and my brother were so
into Yu-Gi-Oh bro we were so into
Yu-Gi-Oh that we you would
um we would print off
uh because we couldn't we had no money
um and my dad or my mum wouldn't buy US
Yu-Gi-Oh cards eventually my dad bought
us some but like my dad wasn't the one
to like even though it was weird like
my dad wasn't like
oh let's just go toy store or something
like that if you're like okay we want
this or whatever he'd never be like all
right get your shoes on let's go throw
something gets her
he would be like if we if we needed
something um
and or if it was a birthday so my dad's
like birthdays and Christmas spoil you
yeah yeah or if you need something for
like school or something he'd you could
ask for anything and he'd get it so if I
need it I remember I need I wanted I was
doing Athletics I had all these
Athletics tournaments and I wanted to
buy spikes
um the running shoes and I was like oh I
want to buy some spikes like can I get
them and then he was like yeah so we
went to shop to get some and they were
like a hundred pounds and I was like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah like he's never
gonna let I thought they were gonna be
like a tenant bro I'm not gonna lie to
you they're so flimsy I thought they
were gonna be like a 10 yeah so I was
like [ __ ] I know one wasted trip and I
was like oh this is the only one they
have he looks he was like oh okay I
didn't say nothing just bought him us
like
yeah bro so I remember that's the kind
of that my dad was but if we could talk
about Yu-Gi-Oh Castillo the Sun comes
home yeah we ain't getting it until it's
someone's birthday I mean that's not
saying get your shoes on let's go toy
shop now it's not happening yeah fair
enough um I like that though yeah it was
good yeah yeah it was good so
um what we used to have to do was go on
Microsoft Word get all the images of the
cards put on a Word document print it
off and cut it out
so we'd be playing Yu-Gi-Oh cards with
the same thing and would stick it
together with glue so it's like the same
one he decided to give it a little bit
of thickness so we'd have to yeah no
yeah it would be one side of the image
was the back of the card and once I was
the front and then we glue it together
and then we'd be playing but obviously
we would only print off the most
ridiculous cards bro we had [ __ ]
um blue eyes white dragon blue eyes
white dragon Dark Magician red eyes
black dragon the flipping
um what uh what's what's my man's name
the uh this is five pieces you get his
arm his leg his face I know what he's I
can't remember but I know oh I can't
remember for the life of me I'm never
gonna remember
um Exodia
Exodia was his name yeah yeah we both
had Exodia so we would just be playing
with ridiculous cards bro yeah yeah are
you stupid it was actually stupid
um but it was fun though if you think
back now you could have probably
laminated and and falsify them as cards
oh no the print quality was terrible oh
is it I was terrible okay okay I'm
thinking about printers nowadays yeah
yeah you're thinking of them inkjets
yeah yeah
we had we had the thing that's got the
line again I don't know about Princess
like that now you youngins uh we
suffered oh yeah yeah yeah the
transition period bro printing one page
back in the day would take like 10
minutes oh my days especially if it's a
picture
Primary School times I used to have the
same way we used to have um
folders and folders of Pokemon cards at
least have folders and folders and
folders of Dragon Ball Z characters are
all printed all color I used to waste
ink I don't know why I used to have them
because it's not like they weren't
Dragon Ball Z cars and like they used to
have them because I always wanted to
draw them in in school I used to draw
them I used to draw them all the time at
school and I always want the best
fusions but I draw this and draw so I
just wanted to be that guy I don't know
why yeah yeah bro I used to waste ink
yeah there's obviously color ink is way
more expensive though oh yeah bro my
parents always used to go off at me
off is that why what are you doing
putting this [ __ ] what are you doing I'm
just oh I'm just sick this is what I
want to do I used to take it to school
and just get another piece of paper and
just trace on it just trace it and be
like gang this is me yes I've just done
one I've just done one Vegeta I've just
done one vegetative I know this is me
bro
everybody
Simpsons characters and I used to trace
it I'd show my stepdad like what is it
look at that amazing you just traced
that and I'm like so that's what I'm
doing oh you're a hater you're a hater I
had booklets of Dragon Ball Z bro
why do we even have one yeah it's a
print [ __ ] for joke oh that's too that's
so funny it's so funny bro the Dragon
Ball Z characters I wanted to be that
guy as well oh I want to be the guy
that's sick of drawing anime characters
back then yeah yeah back then it was the
lick yeah anyway but oh yeah wow bro
that's all I did that's all I did bro my
spare time
um I loved it
this is way this is way past this
happened ages ago okay but I wanted to
speak to you about it and I always kept
forget to speak to you about
how mad is obviously completely
different topic yeah how mad is it about
that um
that racist yeah in Worcester that just
got deleted the one with the which was
going on with the doorman yeah the one
that went viral yeah yeah yeah yeah
but social media social media Justice
these days will just end you yeah of
course of course I'm surprised people
don't take heed into that and they're
like you know what I mean she called him
every name every name under the spot on
the floor everything bro every name
understand she tried to apologize the
next day or whatever interesting was
that actually her because Mad Men are
saying oh it was just faking couch I
don't know I didn't search the account
to find out where they were so basically
yeah she made this like statement like
oh I'm sorry and like she she tried to
use the freedom of speech card in it and
then I spoke to a few men and they were
like oh I think it's like a fake account
because apparently at that time loads of
fake apologies and stuff came out and
some of them are more outrageous than
others all under the same name okay so
no one knows if it was actually her
account it seemed like it possibly could
be because it was like quite sincere
yeah and it was about like oh I left my
ID in my car I didn't want to have to
walk on my face it's very specific to
the situation specific to the video yeah
like you'd have to be a bit of a
sociopath if you just made that up yeah
yeah yeah yeah
um but yeah yeah
it was mad to me that in the space of 24
hours I remember seeing it on someone's
page because it happened in in Worcester
um
or did it happen in Birmingham I can't
remember I think she's from Worcester I
don't know if it happened I think it
happened yeah yeah yeah uh oh yeah she
works for Bosch in Worcester that's it
okay she got sacked I'm not surprised
bro
in the space of 24 hours the video comes
out
and then I saw it on someone's story who
actually lives in in Birmingham so I was
like okay cool happy new Birmingham
then
um and the one the reposter saw it from
was actually from the bouncers page so
he'd put it on his story it was like
I've been bouncing not history he put it
on his um Instagram and was like oh I've
been
working as a doorman for this amount of
time I've seen a lot of [ __ ] but this is
like ridiculous
um and so I saw that and someone
reposted it who actually follows him
anyway and is their friend and stuff
and that was the first one I saw and
you're like oh man that's what a [ __ ]
and then
bro within the space of a tower it was
on people's stories that's that have not
nothing to do with each other I'm seeing
it all over the place yeah and as soon
as I saw it I think I saw it on um
I can't remember maybe one girl that we
went to UNI with or something and she I
think she lives in like Essex and I saw
it in hers like five minutes after I saw
our mothers and she has no relation to
the person that I saw in there as soon
as I saw it on that I was like oh this
girl's done yeah this girl's done at it
and then I saw it on another one and
another one another I was like it's
wrapped I don't know it's a wrap and
then I saw people posting like let's
find who who she is and stuff for oh
Dairy me and then people talk about she
works for this like this is her name she
works for like Bosch or something next
thing you know Bosch is sending out a
tweet saying we don't know who this is
but if she does work for us then does it
anymore
and I was like Wow less than 24 hours my
girl's jobless done
I mean serves you right I've got no pity
towards her yo serves you I have no
pizza but it just astounds me it's like
wow bro if you get caught on camera
doing that it's a rap there's no there's
no judge jury yeah there's it's it's
it's it's a wrap for you bro you're done
people don't learn that's just it people
are stupid man people are stupid they do
stupid things and they
the worst part is the aftermath like the
apology and the or it's just that don't
even bother don't even bother my girl
said she said freedom of speech chest
bro on the video she said everything
with her chest oh she said everything
yeah she said she that's normal for her
it's recreational first yeah that's
normal for her the apology is just like
um it's not really I would I would have
respected I don't respect to her anyway
but I would have been like
if she didn't apologize okay I [ __ ] up
I accept it boom I would have respected
that a lot more
really yeah I would respect to that more
if she was like I'm racist and what
I would respect to the most if she said
that I wouldn't expect her to say that
you know what I mean yeah
so that's why I said I'll respect it
yeah yeah okay I [ __ ] up I take on the
chin boom I'm canceled yeah run this
whole apology thing when she said I've
got black co-workers I'm not even
friends I've got black co-workers and
I've even dated black men in the past
I'm thinking oh babes oh you're just
digging
one of our boys said Saturn that was so
funny yeah that had me crying the other
day yeah he was talking about that thing
yeah that man said
um
he said I wish she didn't say about the
dated black men because the sisters are
gonna hold on to that boy
I was like bro
black women are gonna hold on to that
forever now
like is this what you managed into
it always falls back to demand I'm sorry
I always told that oh wow oh black man
this is what we're into you know swear
down mad that's jokes about Annoying why
is it now our problem
once that the sisters are gonna grip
stop
that's so true
oh it's annoying but it's so true God
hilarious bro
hilarious I was howling
sake they've let us down yeah yeah yeah
let the squad down again oh flipping oh
yeah she's done out here she's done for
bro she is it is I'm like I said no
sympathy man knows if he is what it is
she deserves to be canceled and
she just needs to well for future
reference other people need to just take
that and be like okay cool I just can't
say anything do anything I just need to
be a normal human being you know yeah
bro you literally just need to be a
little normal video
and just watch what you say in mind
where you step and that's it and just
look after yourself car the world the
streets won't look after you boy yeah
bro she said in that thing if that thing
was real she said like ah
but you man like I understand what I did
was wrong but I've lost my job like
livelihood no livelihood you're not know
how that's affected me it's like that's
that's the dice you rolled bro issue now
up in town calling my monkey this an
n-word that spitting on the floor oh
what do you expect brother
babes babes a lot of people see that's
the that's why I don't sympathize with
people like her because that's why I say
this apology thing is so it's so
facetious because
you know what you were saying when you
were saying it oh okay if you were drunk
I don't care where your ID was you know
all these things and it's only because
if she never got fired if she never
if her company stuck behind her if all
these things happen that benefited her
she wouldn't have apologized she would
have gone with her day she wouldn't she
wouldn't they would she would have felt
no need to say oh I've got black
co-workers this oh you are taking my
life with that she would have just
cracked on she would have just and it's
just like your apologies facetious
doesn't mean anything to us yeah it's
pointless bro
Roger dice you gotta deal with the
consequences yeah yeah you haven't got
any co-workers
done out here for a minute you have to
move I hate that my co-workers you know
what is that
what even is that just take your L and
move bro yeah I know you mean if you
just said bro
the game is the game if she would have
if she would have persuaded you know
what the game is a game and I'm gonna
hold this l
I said what I said well you heard me say
it doesn't matter what does it matter if
I'm racist or not yeah it actually
doesn't matter I understand that the
game is the game and it's done the
implications now the implications are
yeah it's tough out here it's tough It's
Hard Out Here for a Pimp so we win some
we lose some imagine that was an ending
speech I would give a round of applause
I'd be like okay fair enough you you you
handed it unexpectedly I rate anyone
who's willing to hold any L with chest I
hear that and just be like that I [ __ ]
up I hear that I don't agree with you
but you [ __ ] up yeah and
um I'm reaping
for the punishment for it boy and it is
what is what do you want me to say the
game is the game the game is the game is
the game because if she didn't say
anything then everyone would be like
yeah she can't win yeah um you said you
had a situation in there yeah so I was
just you know okay so boom
um scenario so when I live with my dad's
um my boyfriend and I used to go out and
get up to stuff in his car we once
parked in a quiet car it would be once
parked in a quiet corner of a pub car
park down the road and started kissing
which led to steamy foreplay binder the
windows is steamed up and we could and
we quickly got carried away with what we
were doing and when 10 minutes later we
heard a knock on our window absolutely
mortified we got ourselves half
respectful and rolled down the window to
an unto an annoyed Patron unbeknownst to
us my boyfriend hadn't put the handbrake
on and we had rolled into the middle of
the car park blocking all other cars
from leaving said the key was three four
cars long and he had
three four of them
waiting to leave with their partners and
families who had been sat in their car
rocking started staring at the rocking
condensed car
what would you do if you were the guy
what do you do if you're the guy in the
car bro the boyfriend
so you're in a whip yeah you've rolled
up to your girl's yard right yeah yeah
sweet one you guys have been four but
you've been throwing Akin for days now
but you've not had a chance to smash
because obviously she lives with her
pups so she's
um your missus is like oh Dad I'm taking
your car out for a spin we're just gonna
go to a little Cinema obviously you bop
out now you're there your lips and lips
and lips in you're doing your things now
babes let me let's let's do a little
thing in there let's do a little thing
yeah man the bed is rocking the car's
rocking now it's steamy you don't feel
nothing you'll get you're in it you're
engulfed in music's playing it's dark
it's like 9 p.m music's music's playing
as dark rocking yep
on the window your startled cars
absolutely startled
quickly get put the boxes on put a t on
roll down the window
all right hey what's up you're well good
you're well gone
um
is that you're blocking the road I can
see your car rocking and it's three on
four of a car we're trying to get out
we're all trying to get out we're tired
it's late it's late so wrap this up
so we can leave
fam
I would literally just have to say my
bad and skirt out that's all
hazards on you know we do the quick
sorry bad my bad let's go I'm not bad oh
it's Peak it's the windscreen steamy and
you have to aircon it and you have to
wait
or just whatever
mortified
mortified one of them ones where you're
both on the same chair as well or you're
both in the same seat because she's
climbed over you've climbed over or
you're both in the back if you're in the
back as a wrap you're both in the back
and they're knocking on the front window
I'll rest me now arrest me now because I
I promise you now if I'm in the back
you're naked naked I'm naked naked and
I'm not opening any windows
I will hide down like that if he's
knocking if you see me he can't see [ __ ]
and he's knocking he can keep knocking
I'm not here
came back in fact you're in the back
seat yeah he keeps knocking and no one's
answering oh yeah I bet you you
um you wait for about a minute and he
stopped knocking right
and you stop so you always start feeling
his mind and pushing the car there's two
or three men then pushing the car now
what do you do you're just sitting there
just
I'll Panic I've I
actually don't know fam neither do I
I would be in such a state you could go
be crying she'll be in Asterix she'll be
so embarrassed for her yeah you want to
get the [ __ ] out yeah your girl will be
crying bro she'll be in hysteric she
wouldn't want anyone to see her
welcome
now I'm just thinking oh okay I will
sign up wow it's just like a pitch black
car park three four cars deep
you've ignored them knocking so two of
them come out start rocking your car nah
bro
yeah that's not bad at all probably
should not stopping
I don't know what I do I don't know how
I'd Escape I don't know what what would
happen
I'm not opening the door they can push
me to where I need to be pushed to yeah
and then just hope it stops I hope
everything stops
what a nightmare Is that real that's
real yeah
break on
how you've not felt that
they will go they would go their Ocean
and the motion in the ocean they thought
that yeah yeah this is me this
aggression has been pent up there we're
going for steamy sex steamy class sex
bangs bangs so uncomfortable bare Bank
very very very uncomfortable but when
it's in oh yes yes even if you can only
move like yeah yeah it's not going for
it
it's wild
it really is wild I haven't painted a
car since I was a team oh I haven't
banged in the car in four or five years
yeah I haven't done it since probably
like 11 years I've done it since I was
young young in the in the clear in the
Clio yeah
oh awful bro all four I remember doing
it one time
it was Daylight outside daylight so
after a night out summer night out me
and my my girlfriend I was up with my
girlfriend at the time just pulled up on
one um like Tesco Express Car Park went
for it bro but it was light so I'm out
here freeing the whole time I was on top
yeah and bro it would be two pumps and
catch
and I've I'm pretty sure I could see one
Don walking but like you know when
you're in it and you just have to keep
moving even when you just like you just
have to just slow it out
just thrust it slow just rock the pelvis
because she at this moment she doesn't
care
yeah yeah
women are the worst yeah women are the
worst once they're in the motion they
don't they don't [ __ ] [ __ ] they don't
give a [ __ ] wow but um
right
foreign
why is Jacob trying to ring me
don't mind I'll ring back in a minute
all right cool so am I there else I am
so me and my girlfriend were chat so me
and my girlfriend were chatting we tell
each other everything so she told me
that there was this guy that kept
disturbing her for her sister's number
so she told her sister and gave
and the sister gave her the impression
to give out the number
so fast forward three weeks later and my
girlfriend's sister's been on a few
dates
and they're on the verge of being a
thing
so her sister gets a call from a random
girl
and says you should leave my boyfriend
alone
the random girl proceeds to post
pictures of them together on her on on
the guys uh WhatsApp status
and the caption is we're here forever
with laughing faces afterwards
so my girlfriend's sister was angry at
her because she's the one that
introduced them
when she told me this I was shocked and
confused because she told me her
sister's got three boyfriends and they
all have different purposes one's got
money the other's got good pipe and she
actually likes the last one
swim uh so I told my girlfriend that her
sister's a thought and she got pissed
off at me and broke up with me am I the
[ __ ] for saying something
message shout out to my Nigerian bro if
you had big fan
my guy
um you need to give me a backdrop of
that again because there's so many sorry
there's boyfriends names so here's
here's the here's the here's the three
fake names so there's
there's Mike yeah and his girlfriend
Toya Mike and Toya yeah yeah so Michael
toy are a thing yeah
um toy is talking to Michael says Ah one
guy keeps hassling with me for my
sister's number
um he's down for my sister I might give
give her the um give him the number let
me just chat to my sister real quick so
Toyo goes to chat to her sister and says
yo there's one dog called Jake Jake
keeps bothering me every day he's
feeling you he's feeling you bro if he
wants your number what are you saying
yeah yeah okay maybe sisters running the
thing send him the eleven yeah send in
the elevens it's all good yeah yeah I
also for nine the guy yeah yeah yeah she
says twice as bet yeah so
um toy goes to Mike says yo this is down
I'm gonna give um Jake the number yeah
she says all right cool
three weeks later everything's blessed
Toya checks in with his sister how's it
going yeah with Mike says I was blessed
he's live his life is live everything's
cool we're born on a few dates a few
nuts everything is blessed it's all
right bet
then she comes in knocking on the door
Toya
you'll never guess what what
look at man status picture of him and
his girl yeah he's got an ex-girlfriend
yeah picture of him and his girl and the
status is we're here forever yeah okay
and this is Rob what's this he says this
[ __ ] just called me said leave him
alone leave Mike alone you never told me
Mike had a boyfriend so I didn't know
this guy had a boyfriend I don't know
him he and Jake you mean Jake Jake Jake
yeah yeah sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
Jake yeah you never told me Jake had a
boyfriend yeah yeah yeah a girlfriend
sorry I didn't know what he's got yeah I
don't know what he's got
he just lost me for your number he just
asked for the digits brother you said
yeah I'm just the middleman here yeah
allow me she's all right whatever man so
they fall out and toys [ __ ] sake why
she fixed at me for yeah and then Mike
sits back and says listen I can't sit
back and handle this anymore my girl's
got three men all that are doing
different things and she's out kicking
fuss at you because something such has
got her her fourth man has a lot of
girlfriends yeah
and she's vexed at you for this um
your girl's a thought what's she talking
about why is she vexed yeah okay I'm
with you now yeah yeah so he's totally
toy yourself my sisters are what yeah
okay my sisters are what
she got three men on the go she's fixed
about number four this is unavailable
yeah and she's where's this title coming
from she's a scared to shut her mouth
I'm here for you I'm not gonna have
anyone I don't care who's I don't know
whose blood is what this is me and you
babes I ride for you and Tori says wow
my sister you know you think you can
come up with my other call my sister
scared get out
I says what she's gout
excited
you have me get out
of what are you even doing here get out
talking about this isn't us this is me
and her yeah get out
so man hit up the SMG said fellas
great reenactment I see it now yeah yeah
yeah without names it's so hard when
it's gone
um no he's not no he's not the [ __ ]
he's not the artist he was writing for
his goal yeah and then the girl's being
a [ __ ] he wasn't the family's Corner
yeah he was trying to yeah he's trying
to speak the truth trying to speak real
the sister he was just a hypocrite Lewis
is a hypocrite and a thought she is a
thought yeah
Own It Toyota's deluded obviously little
sister she's family so she's trying to
protect her she doesn't want her to be
called anything but Toya must know that
little sister Sophia is a scat she is a
scare Sofia the sketchy is a scat she
just doesn't want to tell her that she's
a scared yeah she wants she doesn't want
to believe that she's in denial she's
being dumb bruv she's being she's a skit
shut up is there things that open a
short case there's no discussion about
it yeah yeah you're in the right my G
Toya's in the wrong Sophia's clearly in
the wrong and it just is what is his
karma really is this what's his bro is
things done sorry
um sorry yeah you got one's gotta go oh
yeah I forgot about that I actually do
make it quick
so to wrap up the episode guys um one's
gotta go this one is a mix it's a mix of
TV and uh people
uh so one's got to go That 70s Show
Saved by the Bell Sister Sister fresh
prince of Bella Same by the Bell why I
never [ __ ] with Saved by the Bell ever
I thought it was okay okay but it was
never like a thing for me okay yeah yeah
never like a thing for me it's just it
was whack say a butterball's trash okay
yeah yeah all right Matilda Jumanji Home
Alone Mrs Doubtfire
Matilda Jumanji Home Alone Mrs Doubtfire
obviously like the old school Jumanji
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know what this
is actually controversial as hell I
don't [ __ ] with Home Alone that much
I don't [ __ ] Home Alone that much
it's kind of [ __ ]
it's a staple Christmas movie G it's a
Homeland one and two
classics classics I know they're
Classics bro but all of those are
Classics this is doubtfire's legit tool
now and I know but like so is home alone
bro I watched home alone last year ah
bro
home alone's like it's cool in that
that's not when you watch it when was
the last time I do not smile when I
watch that film
I just watch it straight face when was
the last time you watched it I don't
know man three four years ago bro it's
staple man I know I know why it's stable
I know it's a classic bro but I'm
telling you I don't smile in the thing
it doesn't bring me any Joy I just watch
it because it's okay okay let's move on
all right
um this is in terms of their filmography
yeah so Steve Carell Jim Carrey Seth
Rogen Jonah Hill oh
I'll say them again Steve Carell Jim
Carrey Seth Rogan Jonah Hill
damn
controversial again if it wasn't for the
office I would say Steve Carell because
Evan Almighty was [ __ ] I can't remember
it [ __ ] was he in heaven Almighty he's
Evan Steve Carell is Evan oh sure yeah
never know why yeah I completely forgot
um
Jim Carrey's a Legend
um I'm actually gonna say Seth Rogen
okay
he's a better writer
than he is in it just in that lineup I
think Seth Rogen is great yeah and he
does really good writing and directing
but just in terms of movies he's in as
an actor he doesn't stand up to
definitely not Jim Carrey yeah
definitely not Jonah Hill's Journey
Hills Jonah Hill's a Madman Jonah Hill
is OnStar he's got um what's the word
he's got diversity yeah he's got
diabetes
Steve Carell Steve Carell are and Seth
Rogen I like that to me but the office
it just bumps him yeah the office is
great yeah office is fantastic office is
amazing so yeah um okay Drew Hill
112.
Boyz II Men new edition
I can't even think of a Drew Hill song
um I think I've got a Drew Hill song is
that um is Julio the one who's like um
somebody sleeping in my bed as well
had a couple bags yeah uh 112. that
peaches and cream oh what 112 song have
I got in um
um
oh 112 songs I forgot um
what is this number
um one to our Boys to Men and what was
the last one New Edition new edition
New Edition bags as well can you stand
the rain in June [ __ ]
[ __ ] Bobby Brown times yeah old school
Bobby Brown wow I'm actually gonna have
to say Drew Hill okay I'm surprised but
if I didn't know who you'd pick but I'm
just surprised and this is you this will
make sense anyway so Heath Ledger uh
Jacqueline Phoenix uh Jared Leto and
Mark Hamill Markham was the voice actor
for the Joker so all of these are
obviously related to The Joker
say them again Heath Ledger Jacqueline
Phoenix Jared Leto and Mark Hamill
Gerald Lowe
yeah man in comparison he's a big thing
bro he's not up in there he is because
he was only a Suicide Squad right yeah
Suicide Squad I think he's in the Snyder
cup of Justice League as well I've heard
I've heard I've not seen that movie yeah
but he's begging it bro he's not up
there yet he's not up there yet he was
Vex apparently he I pretty sought pretty
sure he sued
when Joaquin Phoenix got Joker really
he's super because he had a contract to
be Joker Joker or whatever and then when
they went back in Phoenix he was kicking
off bro oh really justifiably but hey
you couldn't bring he hasn't got that
kind of smoke bro what Phoenix brought
to that movie was different yeah played
it well yeah could you like to watch
that movie and think all right man yeah
yeah yeah I can't do that I couldn't do
that yeah I couldn't bring that kind of
smoke so here's what it is bro TL you
have to find out all right so you're
ones that I've got to go I Saved by the
Bell Home Alone Seth Rogen Drew Hill and
Jared Leto there you go one okay good
episode guys catch you in a little bit
next week
[Music]
foreign
[Music]